hi I'm Deadpool the other jolly guy in a
red suit with a Lapworth sitting on here
to tell you happy holidays in the spirit
of this most festive time of year I've
decided to release my holiday cheer all
over the world so sit back hold on your
ornaments
ghazal a little eggnog at least that
looks like eggnog and prepare yourself
because it's time for Saint Wade to put
the wind in winter wonderland everybody
Merry Christmas happy Festivus from
Deadpool since is the holidays I wanted
to do a new Deadpool video this is gonna
be my top 5 Deadpool Christmas stories
also give an update about what's going
on with Deadpool - they're getting ready
to ramp up their promotional tour
because the movies coming out in June
instead of February this year so be sure
to subscribe to get everything and I'll
try to think of some sort of Deadpool
themed giveaway but for now it's just
gonna be the Infinity Gauntlet so I'll
explain that at the end of the video
while the Christmas pulak burns let's
remember back to Christmas 2015 the 12
days of Deadpool was probably one of the
most innovative marketing campaigns from
any movie that had happened so far was
the week before Christmas in all around
town bball fans were dying to watch
LeBron Steph and Russell's bow down she
bring back the short shorts who wears
short shorts I do I wear shirts a
basketball miracle right here on
Christmas Day stuffed into our stockings
by the Jolly NBA join us for games who
win something else cool see you on
Christmas boys and girls
in what we found out later is that yeah
they had a really good marketing team
but it was largely based on the
suggestions from Ryan Reynolds that they
were doing all those things so you just
have to admire how awesome he is in
addition to all the stuff that Deadpool
is doing probably the best holiday
themed promotion that they've done
lately is the Good Housekeeping holiday
issue he guests edited it I did a video
for that so I'll link it at the end of
this but it's basically just him
Deadpool lysing an issue of Good
Housekeeping and I think that's part of
the charm of the character is that he
shows up places during a lot of these
promotions that you don't expect him
like everybody expects a straight up
trailer but it's when they flip that on
its head that it actually becomes
interesting and more people pay
attention to it that otherwise would
have just ignored it but the other top
stories some of these will seem familiar
like Deadpool vs. Santa Claus
earning with Spidy pool spider-man and
Deadpool Volume one number 12 which was
basically their holiday issue because it
fell during the month of December so
most of these Deadpool holiday themed
stories are holiday themed because they
just happened to fall during the month
of December the actual story of the
issue is this murder the deadpool and
spiderman have to solve that turns out
to be perpetrated by a santa claus who's
really the god Saturn dressed up as
Santa Claus who is pissed that Christmas
has stole his holiday of Saturnalia
which usually take place from December
17th to the 23rd so he wants to take it
back by force literally so they have to
find a way to stop him but because it's
a bit of a Marvel holiday issue they
work in a lot of other Christmas jokes
that you wouldn't see in a normal comic
book Captain America gets Miles Morales
a vacuum cleaner like there's just a lot
of funny jokes about them giving gifts
to each other but talk about meta Easter
eggs so right now James Franco released
the disaster artist movie which is about
the real-life making of the room movie
probably one of the best worst movies in
the history of movies action I did not
hit her it's not true it's [ __ ] I
did not hit her I did not oh hi mark
during the issue Deadpool named drops
Tommy was so and calls him an alien and
if you have any idea who Tommy Wiseau is
you think that that is spot-on he 100%
feels like he could be from another
planet the next one is the Deadpool Max
holiday issue now the story itself isn't
that great and a little problematic but
they have some of the best jokes about
different holidays in it so they just
proceeded to make fun of every single
holiday from every single religion
possible which is only something that
Deadpool could get away with like he's
supposed to be the most offensive
character so expecting that from him you
don't feel quite as bad about some of
the things that he takes shots at it'll
be interesting to see how far they push
that during the Deadpool TV series next
year we haven't seen any footage from
that we only know that it's going to be
a hard or adult animated series so I'm
assuming that pretty much anything the
Deadpool has done is fair game as long
as it makes for good TV the next one is
a little more self-contained but it
teases this secret history between
a clause in Deadpool so it's Marvel
holiday magazine number one it's
basically a self-contained Deadpool
story inside that issue where he goes
after Santa Claus but then winds up
teaming up with him against someone
named bass Rankin which is just a
reference to the rankin/bass holiday
cartoons like Rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer or the year without Santa Claus
things like that santa chills on the
naughty list after deadpool saves him
from a Yeti
so it's complete nonsense which is every
single holiday Christmas reference you
could imagine packed into it you truly
are the king of kings the next one is
from Deadpool Volume one number 34
Deadpool vs Santa Claus again recurring
theme in the Deadpool comics that he
winds up fighting Santa Claus on several
occasions he's remembering working for
the kingpin as a hitman
so the kingpin wants him to kill a union
figure who's actually posing as Santa
Claus during the holidays so while he
fails to kill him earlier in the day
later he finds him at a shopping mall
with all these kids on his lap doing the
Santa Claus thing takes him down then
showing what a nice guy he is puts on
the dead person Santa Claus outfit and
continues to listen to all the kids
Christmas wishes and if you're a big
Deadpool Deathstroke fan this was
actually written by Christopher priest
who wrote Deathstroke rebirth more
recently so all the funny jokes about
how Deadpool is like a clone of
Deathstroke with spider-man colors like
Spider Man with swords made to look like
Deathstroke Christopher priest has
written both of those characters but let
me know in the comments what your
favorite deadpool holiday theme story it
doesn't have to be from christmas it
could be from any other holiday there's
a lot of Deadpool Halloween stories too
there was actually a time where he wound
up at a Halloween cosplay party where a
bunch of people were dressed up like
Deadpool and he wound up making fun of
himself via the other characters like
how come these people are dressed up
like this stupid person for those of you
asking about Deadpool - what'll probably
happen is is if they don't drop a Super
Bowl trailer is they'll start promoting
the movie a little bit around then and
then just ramp up till they get within
about two months and then really start
dumping all the cool footage but don't
forget that they also have new mutants
coming out in April so I'm also
expecting them to attach some Deadpool
to that - but because infinity war is
such a big deal
there's no way they're gonna let that
pass without Deadpool posting some
parody teasers just making fun of all
those characters
not on my watch [ __ ] so like
this chubby security guard that's
wearing a stark nametag and just happens
to look a little bit like Tony Stark if
he gained about a hundred pounds they'll
probably be doing more stuff like that
but like I said there's a new round of
that Infinity Gauntlet replica giveaway
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
I'll just name a new winner when I post
a new Marvel video leave all your Marvel
video requests in the comments below
there's actually some new Iron Man stuff
from Infinity Ward that I want to post
that'll either be tomorrow or the day
after that but click here for my new
Deadpool trailer video and click here
for my breakdown to that funny Good
Housekeeping promo thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome Happy
Holidays
you